oui
[Musique]
je suis officier vernazza vous avez
l'impression que les autres profitent de
la vie et qu'il vous manque quelque
chose on a tous cette impression de
temps à autre et la science à un mot
pour ce phénomène nous discutons avec le
capital risqueur qui a inventé
l'expression forme au fear of missing
out la peur de rater quelque chose
patrick mcginnis
[Musique]
patrick mcginnis vous êtes capital
risqueurs et comme vous le dites vous
même le premier fomo sapiens que la
science connaissent très heureuse de
vous avoir avec mon patrick bonjour
bonjour sophy très heureux d'être avec
vous bon même si le mot est facile à
retenir et désormais a déjà célèbre ça
serait bien d'expliquer à nos
téléspectateurs donc brièvement qu'est
ce qu'est exactement le faux mot
acronyme anglais pour la peur de rater
quelque chose est ce un syndrome un état
qu'est ce que c'est oui donc le faux mot
c'est une anxiété causé par la peur à
l'idée qu'il y ait quelque chose de plus
intéressant dans le monde que ce que
vous êtes en train de faire en ce moment
est combiné à la peur d'être exclu d'une
expérience collective bénéfique est
d'être exclu de quelque chose de
collectif que vous voyez se produire et
dont vous ne faites pas partie
et vous dites que vous êtes le premier
fomo sapience de l'histoire comment se
fait-il qu'il n'y en ait pas eu avant
vous
et bien l'expression fomo n'existait pas
avant moi j'ai inventé quand j'étais
étudiant à harvard business school il ya
longtemps en 2003 si vous pouvez
imaginer ça à ces sentiments font bien
sûr partie de l'expérience humaine parce
que depuis le début de l'humanité mais
je dirais que nous n'avions pas besoin
du terme fromeaux jusqu'à l'arrivée dès
réseaux sociaux j'ai inventé ce mot et
ça a parfaitement match et avec la
diffusion d'internet et des réseaux
sociaux
ok d'accord une petite question qui me
vient comme ça est ce que vous avez fait
de l'argent avec l'expression en forme
parce que ça vous a rendu riche
et bien voilà comment ça se passe
heureusement j'ai gagné un peu d'argent
grâce au faux moore je fais beaucoup de
séminaires auprès d'entreprises de gens
j'ai écrit un livre qui s'appelle fear
of missing out et j'ai un podcast qui
s'appelle fomo sapiens ah mais vous
savez même si j'ai déposé le terme fomo
sapiens la réalité c'est quand vous
inventer un mot personne ne vous envoie
de chèques et donc vous avez juste la
joie de voir votre terme utilisé c'est
votre récompense la plupart du temps une
autre petite question est ce que feu -
n'est pas juste un mot un peu original
que vous avez inventé pour parler de l'
envie de la jalousie quelle est la
différence entre l'envi et le faux mots
alors à la différence c'est que quand
vous êtes en proie aux faux mais vous
savez je pense que à l'envi c'est ce
genre de choses qui remonte aux débuts
de l'humanité pensez à la bible avec
kane et abel ce meurtre a été motivée
par l'envié cela fait partie de notre
condition d'être humain la différence du
faux mots c'est que le faux mot traduit
le fait que nous vivons à une époque où
nous recevons au quotidien énormément
d'informations et qui n'ont aucun lien
avec la réalité pensez aux réseaux
sociaux les gens mettent des filtres il
se met en scène de manière totalement
est réel donc quand on vit en faut mais
il y adeux l'envi mais plus encore il
s'agit d'être envieux face à quelque
chose qui n'existe peut-être pas et
c'est aussi lié au fait qu'en tant
qu'être humain nous voulons faire partie
du groupe quand vous voyez les queue
devant l'apple store quand vous voyez
les que vous savez a devant les
restaurants aux spectacles les plus
populaires il nous est inconfortable de
voir que nous n'en faisons pas partie
donc il y a effectivement de l'envi mais
je pense aussi que la différence entre
le faux mots et lent vie et c'est qu'il
y ait un profond sentiment de vouloir
appartenir à quelque chose et non d'être
exclu de quelque chose qui est en train
de se passer
quelque chose est une illusion c'est ça
oui je veux dire le problème du faux
moleux truc qui est vraiment
problématique et qui est la raison pour
laquelle j'ai décidé de passer tant de
temps à essayer d'aider les gens c'est
que quand vous êtes en proie aux faux
moa vous n'êtes pas en train de penser
au monde qui vous entoure vous ne pensez
pas au fait que quelque chose existe ou
n'existe pas dans le monde réel vous
êtes globalement en train de vous
inventer des histoires vous êtes en
train de remplir les espaces vides et
vous dites par exemple ok bon mes
copains sont à une soirée j'ai été à des
millions de soirée je sais ce que c'est
qu'une soirée mais je commence à trop
réfléchir et je m'imagine que c'est la
meilleure soirée de tous les temps et
donc vous êtes assis là à vous dire que
votre vie n'est pas bien vous déprécier
ce que vous avez au profit de quelque
chose qui ne correspond sans doute même
pas la réalité
je me surprends à faire ça dernièrement
parce que je viens de donner naissance à
un enfant c'était ma décision pendant la
pandémie
restez à la maison passer la grossesse à
la maison accoucher à la maison je vous
parle ici de mon propre jardin parce que
vous savez j'ai toujours peur de sortir
alors que je me suis fait vacciner et
maintenant que j'ai été aussi associé à
la cause de tout cela le bébé le
coronavirus etc je le retrouve à faire
un défilé instagram ce que je ne faisais
jamais auparavant oh mon dieu quelle vie
merveilleuse les gens 11 et cela alors
que je vis la période la plus heureuse
de ma vie je veux dire je pense que je
n'ai jamais été aussi heureuse depuis
que je suis maman donc oui c'est quelque
chose d'étrange je ne suis pas sûr de
savoir comment y faire face cela dit
bien sophie tout d'abord félicitations
ce sont d'excellentes nouvelles merci
ensuite je vais vous dire quelque chose
ce n'est pas votre faute ok donc il y a
deux choses qui ont lieu
la première est que pendant votre
confinement congé maternité vous avez
laissé le monde derrière vous et vous
êtes entré dans une très petite bulle
mais vous y avez emporté quelque chose
votre ami là le téléphone
et ce téléphone on avons tous jamais
passé autant de temps sur nos téléphones
que maintenant je regarde mes
statistiques et particulièrement durant
le long confinement de l'année dernière
c'était comme un mécanisme de secours
pour faire face à l'absence de contacts
humains c'est la première chose la
seconde est kunsten g est conçu à la
base pour vous faire ressentir le faux
mot
notification image idéalisée on sait
jean mélangés à des célébrités et c'est
comme si vous mélangez vos amis avec des
célébrités et donc vous commencez à tout
embrouiller est à comparer votre vie non
seulement à celle de ceux qui sont
autour de vous mais et même si vous êtes
déjà une célébrité avec celle de ceux
qui ont une vie encore plus fantastique
que la vôtre
tout cela à prix d'ensemble vous
manipulent c'est une chose à laquelle
nous sommes tous confrontés et donc
quand les dés sont pipés en votre
défaveur quand le jeu est organisé de
manière injuste envers vous et s'appuie
sur ses faiblesses psychologiques que
nous avons tous vous commencez à
comprendre que c'est bon vous pouvez
vous battre contre ça
ok donc est ce que le film ont fait
partie de l'effet de meute j'allais
parler d'immunité de meute
absolument en fait quand je parlais du
faux mots à penser à ce qu'elles font
mots nous sommes trois hauts-fourneaux
décisions sont affectés par des facteurs
externes quand c'est un grand artiste
comme jay cocks qui combine ce qui vous
prenez à n'importe quel artiste russe il
ne se levaient pas le matin en se disant
ok qu'est ce que les autres sont en
train de faire je vais les copier non il
absorbait le monde et créer de nouvelles
choses il ne faisait pas que suivre nous
sommes en profond mots on est dans les
instincts de l'effet de meute riz il
connaît les noms qui traverse le
serengeti il reste entrepôts car ils ne
veulent pas être attaqué par un
prédateur en fait cette partie de
l'instinct humain c'est opter pour la
survie qu'offre le groupe mais à cause
du faux mots ou ne prend pas des
décisions qu'on veut vraiment prendre
nous faisons partie d'un groupe nous
sommes des suiveurs et donc on ne peut
rien faire de vraiment grands car les
suiveurs ne peuvent pas être originaux
ils ne peuvent pas inventer de nouvelles
choses qui se contente de suivre la
foule voilà pourquoi le faux mot est si
problématique pour moi
est ce que vous êtes en train de dire
que ceux qui créent et qui invente de
nouveaux programmes informatiques
compose de la grande musique et sont de
grands films
je pense que le fond mots et présents
dans la sphère artistique car les
artistes sont en concurrence et
lorsqu'ils voient leurs amis devenir
célèbre et euh non je veux dire je le
vois dans le monde des auteurs vous
connaissez quelqu'un dont le livre se
vend très bien et vous vous dites le
mien n'a pas fait aussi bien c'est un
instinct humain naturel que de se
comparer aux autres bien sûr comme nous
en parlions ça ne correspond peut-être
pas la réalité
je dirais qu'un véritable grand artiste
créateur businessman doit se détacher du
faux mots il faut reconnaître que la
grandeur vient de l'originalité et de la
création de nouvelles choses et de ne
pas regarder ce que la masse est en
train de faire
le facile à dire qu'à faire n'êtes vous
pas d'accord car je me demande si je
passe mes journées à faire défiler
instagram
et à regarder tous les trucs géniaux que
les autres font est ce que cela implique
forcément que je ne suis pas satisfaite
sans ma propre vie
oui c'est bien plus facile à dire qu'à
faire en fait ce que nous savons c'est
que des recherches ont montré et je m'en
suis aperçu en écrivant mon livre
c'était incroyable il y a des centaines
de pages d'articles psychologique sur le
fond mot est des gens dédier une partie
de leur carrière à l'étude du faux mot
et c'est qu'il ya un lien très claire
entre l'utilisation des réseaux sociaux
il faut mots donc plus vous utilisez les
réseaux sociaux plus vous vous sentez
déprimé et plus vous êtes en prof au mot
et plus vous utilisez réseaux sociaux
j'ai donc il ya un cercle vicieux et
donc vous savez je pense que ça nous
renvoie à la question de l'importance
des informations que vous absorbez quand
vous voulez faire quelque chose
d'original ou être un leader d'où
tirez-vous vos stimulation et idée et si
vous le faites que vous comparer aux
autres vous entraver votre potentiel
êtes vous totalement faux vos frais
non absolument pas
il faut bien que je la vole
bien voilà que je vis à new york je vis
dans le quartier de tribeca et nous
sommes à 90 % vacciner on n'a même pas
eu un cas on en moins
donc on retourne à la vie normale j'ai
là autant d'opportunités d'invitation de
choses à faire j'ai compris que j'étais
en contact avec mon faux mots
parce que je comprends que c'est quelque
chose d'inévitable mais ce que j'essaie
de faire c'est de le gérer
je fais un certain nombre de choses je
fais très attention en utilisant mes
appareils et je réfléchis à pourquoi je
fais les choses donc tout en
reconnaissant que j'ai beaucoup de faux
mot à ce que j'essaie de faire c'est de
le gérer pour ne pas passer mon temps à
faire des choses que je ne veux pas
vraiment faire juste parce que tout le
monde l'ait fait
nous allons faire une courte pause puis
nous reprendrons notre discussion avec
l'homme qui a inventé l'expression fomo
patrick mcginnis rester avec
[Musique]
alors nous sommes de retour avec patrick
mcginnis capital risqueur qui a inventé
l'expression fomo patrie est ce que le
fonds peut être justifié vous avez
dressé une liste de marqueurs en
écrivant au sujet du flow mot et l'un
d'entre eux est d'avoir peur que
d'autres et une vie plus intéressante
que la nôtre que faire si c'est vrai par
exemple je suis coincé à devoir
rembourser mon prêt étudiant avec un
travail cauchemardesque alors que ma
copine d'université fait une tournée
promotionnelle pour son livre en europe
est-ce qu'elle n'a pas une meilleure vie
que la mienne
eh bien je pense qu'en réalité
probablement pas parce que elle est
tournée promotionnelle sont épuisantes
se met ça rend bien sur instagram c'est
tout la réalité est que c'est toujours
plus enrichissant que disons être dans
un bureau de 9h à 17h à faire quelque
chose qui nous intéresse pas parce qu'il
faut rembourser un emprunt
absolument d'accord et c'est la beauté
du faubourg parce que le faux mot n'est
pas toujours un mal en fait le faux mot
peut nous montrer où nous voulons
emotionnellement nous trouver les choses
que nous voudrions faire donc par
exemple si vous avez un ami qui montrent
une entreprise et que vous travaillez de
9 heures à 17 heures dans une entreprise
vous pouvez vous dire aux j'aimerais
vraiment faire ça ou si votre ami court
le marathon et que vous voyez ça sur
instagram vous pouvez vous dire aux
j'aimerais vraiment courir un marathon
la chose importante à faire quand on a
ce sentiment est d'être sûr qu'on n'est
pas seulement en train d'adopter la
perception que la chose en question est
bien d'accord est une tentation au
salaire si croule je veux faire ça j'en
crève dans vie au pays c'est la première
étape ensuite soyons sérieux avez vous
le faire est-ce que c'est aussi bien que
ça en a l'air est ce que vous aimez bien
faire ça donc ce que je conseille aux
gens c'est d'y aller doucement par
exemple si vous pensez que vous voulez
faire un marathon ne commencez pas par
vous entraîner pour le marathon le
lendemain entraînez-vous pour un 10 km
20 km si vous voulez monter une boîte ne
quittez pas votre emploi pour essayer de
comprendre quoi faire monter une affaire
à côté et j'écris beaucoup à ce sujet
dans le livre il s'agit de démystifier
les choses aborder ce qui semble si bien
en faisant expérience dans la réalité
pour décider si cela nous convient ou
non et une fois que vous avez fait ça
vous pouvez prendre votre décision
d'être non plus rationnelle est ce que
cette chose valait tout ce faux mots et
puis pensez à l'immigration dans le
monde quand les gens il ya une centaine
d'années je dirais aller vers le nouveau
monde depuis l'europe ont peu importe où
sont allés les gens en fonction des
époques il était poussé par le fonds
mots il voyait ce monde qui semblait
fantastique ils voyaient leurs amis
quitté leur pays pour aller là bas et ce
n'était pas facile bien sûr mais ces
gens étaient ambitieux et je pense que
toute personne ayant de l'ambition
prendra des risques pour aller vers
quelque chose qui à l'air fantastique et
j'encourage les gens à reconnaître que
le faux mot est bien réelle à
reconnaître que ça peut être un
incroyable catalyseur mais il ne faut
pas y aller direct il faut apprendre le
plus possible essayez de comprendre
aussi le rêve est réel parce que vous ne
voulez pas par exemple aller dans un
autre pays avant de vous apercevoir que
vous en détester le climat ou que vous
en détester les gens et que vous voulez
être chez vous ce n'est pas l'endroit
idéal
déclinée avec l'âge est ce grâce à la
sagesse qui généralement apporte une
certaine sérénité face à la vie disons
que j'ai 65 ans est ce que je suis
immunisé contre le faux mots
alors comment ça marche le fond mauve
fonctionne à partir de deux choses la
première est le temps que vous passez à
vous comparer à d'autres la seconde et
l'expérience que vous avez de la vie
afin de pouvoir déterminer est si ce que
vous observez est aussi bien que cela en
a l'air quand vous recevez ces signaux
extérieurs donc quand vous êtes jeunes
tout semble fantastique quand vous êtes
allé à un million de soirée vous vous
dites bon je sais que c'est une soirée
je peux y aller ou pas je sais comment
ça va être de la même manière quand on
est jeune on a beaucoup plus de temps
pour absorber le monde quand vous êtes
dans la trentaine la quarantaine vous
êtes occupé vous vous dites que vous
n'avez pas le temps de vous focaliser
sur tous ces trucs que vous essayez de
faire votre travail de vous occuper de
votre famille toutes ces importantes
responsabilités que vous avez il est
intéressant que vous ayez mentionné
l'âge de 65 ans ce qui arrive avec la
vieillesse c'est bien que vous gagner en
sagesse et la sagesse est quelque chose
de puissant
et vous avez aussi plus de temps et plus
important encore vous avez commencé à
comprendre que vous n'alliez pas vivre
éternellement donc les choses que vous
voulez faire dans votre vie que ce soit
un voyage à voir des parties du monde
que vous aviez toujours voulu explorer
que ce soit passé du temps avec vos
petits enfants vous comprenez qu'il faut
aller vers l'essence des choses et donc
le faux mot devient plus fort car vous
comprenez que la vie est précieuse et
courte et que vous devez faire le
maximum de choses que vous pouvez faire
avant d'en être incapable
c'est plus qu'un simple acronyme il ya
aussi le pho bo offir un peu bizarre
option d'où vient le faux bond et
comment est ce qu'il y ait au fond
en fait et j'ai inventé ces deux mots au
même moment quand j'étais à harvard et
j'ai écrit un article dans le journal de
l'école qui s'intitulait social théorie
à edge bs mcginnis tout faux c'était un
sujet du faux mot qui est devenu un mot
célèbre dans le monde entier vous savez
quand vous regardez sur google il ya 50
millions d'occurrences et puis il ya le
feu ben qui n'est malheureusement pas
devenu aussi célèbre ce qui est
regrettable car à mon sens c'est un peu
gros problème pho bo veut dire fear of a
better option c'est l'idée selon
laquelle par exemple vous allez sur
amazon pour acheter une paire de lacets
blancs il y à plus de 1000 options
possibles et elles sont toutes très bien
mais il ya tellement d'informations vous
ne savez même pas quoi faire ça vous
dépasse et vous finissez par ne rien
choisir du tout parce que vous pourriez
bien trouver quelque chose de mieux plus
tard
donc c'est l'idée selon laquelle nous
attendons la perfection est temps
qu'elle n'est pas là nous ne nous
décidons pas nous renvoyons la décision
à plus tard nous sommes coincés
d'accord est ce que cela veut dire que
nous devrions toujours choisir plus
rapidement et être plus décisif dans nos
choix même si cela veut dire qu'on ne
fait pas toujours le meilleur choix pour
soi même afin de rester mentalement sain
et éviter le faux bond
c'est ce qu'on devrait faire
mialy vraiment très intéressant qui
s'intitule the paradox of choice de
barry schwartz ce livre est sorti
l'année où j'ai inventé le terme faut
beau mais ils ont beaucoup en commun la
puissante idée qui développe et que les
gens qui sont très difficiles l es gens
qui cherchent la décision optimale
parfaite dépense beaucoup plus de temps
et d'énergie ils prennent de meilleures
décisions d'accord mais la réalité est
qu'ils ont dépensé tant de temps et
d'énergie qu'ils finissent souvent par
regretter de ne pas avoir pris un autre
chemin choisi d'autres choses beaucoup
plus que ceux qui ont choisi en se
disant ça suffit comme ça même si ce
n'est pas aussi bien que dans le cas de
celui qui a dépensé tout ce temps et
cette énergie ils n'ont pas ses regrets
les gens qui choisissent plus vite sont
en fin de compte plus satisfait
face au football à prendre donc à
choisir ce qu'on veut vraiment ou
choisir et ne pas regarder en arrière
c'est un bon conseil mais comment faire
ça exactement je veux dire comment
savoir ce que je veux vraiment
c'est l'éternel défi de l'être humain
n'est ce pas mais la réalité est qu'il
ya un processus vous savez j'ai donné
une conférence sur la plateforme ted sur
ça elle s'intitulait comment prendre des
décisions plus rapidement parce que j'en
ai souffert moi même et donc cette
conférence stades a fait je crois 1,5
million de vues les gens apprécient
beaucoup est ce que je dis aux gens et
c'est qu'il ya trois types de décisions
dans la vie il ya les décisions enjeux
élevés les décision arrange faible et
les décisions sans enjeu une décision
sans enjeu c'est par exemple résoudre à
la question avait commandé du poulet ou
du poisson
cela n'a aucune importance les deux
iront donc je tire à pile ou face parce
que je ne veux pas décider quelque chose
d'aussi peu importants je fais ça tout
le temps est-ce que je vais aller courir
aujourd'hui je ne sais pas pile ou face
voilà c'est fait j'ai économisé beaucoup
de ton car j'aurais pu passer vingt
minutes à cogiter les seconds sont les
décisions en jeu faible ce sont des
choses qui demandent un peu plus de
temps par exemple quelle télé devrait
acheter voilà c'est ce que je fais
voyez-vous assez que je prends des
critères de base je veux une certaine
taille dépenser une certaine somme et
puis je sous traite cette question
trouvons quelqu'un qui on sait plus que
moi je lui dit littéralement je n'arrive
pas à me décider peux tu me dire ce que
je devrais faire je fais ça depuis des
années c'est kim a économisé beaucoup de
temps et d'énergie et je n'ai aucun
regret enfin les choses importantes de
la vie ce sont les décisions enjeux
élevés là il faut s'asseoir et bien
passé en revue les critères quels sont
les critères de base ensuite il faut
penser à quelles options coïncide avec
ces critères les étudier tout et même
tous couchés sur un papier car quand
vous écrivez les choses deviennent plus
concrète ensuite je prends à l'une
d'elles et je me dis ok très pourrait
être la meilleure ensuite je la compare
avec toutes les options une à une et
j'élimine l'une des deux je les compare
on enlève une gare de l'autre et je fais
cela afin de n'en avoir plus qu'une et
la force de cette méthode la raison pour
laquelle ça marche et c'est que quand on
procède ainsi au convainc notre cerveau
qu'on obtient systématiquement la
meilleure des deux options en
travaillant par élimination en
permanence nous n'avons pas la tentation
de revenir à une option dont nous nous
sommes débarrassés et nous évitons cette
psychologie qui consiste à toujours
revenir en arrière sans rien éliminé à
toujours revenir sur les mêmes choses en
permanence en procédant ainsi on arrive
à une décision avec lesquels on peut
vivre et la bonne nouvelle est que quand
vous êtes en proie au faubourg toutes
vos options sont bonnes vous ne pouvez
jamais perdre c'est la force du faux
beau vous essayez de vous sortir de la
tête cette peur est de baser vos
décisions sur les faits
le faux bond et le faux mots sont
épuisants mais si on les combine ont
créé un monstre encore plus effrayant
c'est le faudra fear of the wind in fine
selon vous c'est ça
c'est exact info da c'est la peur ultime
vous savez quand vous ne pouvez pas vous
lever le matin on voit ça en particulier
avec des gens qui ont plein d'options
dans la vie en grandissant on a plus de
succès et les gens commencent à vous
offrir des choses en permanence vous
avez aussi plus d'argent à dépenser
d'accord et quand vous commencez alors à
voir que certains des gens qui ont connu
le plus de succès et qui sont les plus
riches
sont ceux qui ont le plus de mal à
prendre des décisions parce qu'ils ont
tous se font mouche leurs amis sont
fantastiques ils font des choses
fabuleuses et donc ils se disent oh je
pourrais passer mon été à voyager je
pourrais aller à capri dans le sud de la
franche pour elle à new york ou à moscou
ce peu importe mais en même temps ils
ont tellement d'opportunités d'options
que ça les dépasse ils ne peuvent pas
décider et ils finissent par ne rien
faire et j'ai constaté cela chez des
amis ils ont des dizaines d'idées pour
leurs vacances et ils finissent par
aller nulle part
d'accord j'ai l'impression que le flou
il le faut beau sont encore renforcées
par le fait que nous vivons dans une
société où il ya un vrai culte du succès
le succès tout je veux dire je pensais
qu'on allait vers un monde où le bonheur
serait plus important que le succès mais
en fait non les gens qui ont du succès
vous regarde depuis la télévision et
vous disent ça sont qui soit comme moi
cela peut sembler idiot mais c'est
plutôt cool de dormir quatre heures par
jour et de se vanter de faire travailler
son cerveau à ne plus en pouvoir est ce
que le frigo et le football sont des
effets secondaires de cette idéologie ou
le succès compte le plus
oui je pense que vous avez raison elle
c'est quelque chose à laquelle je
n'avais pas pensé mais si vous pensez à
la seule culture la culture de
l'agitation prenez elon musk par exemple
elon musk et port très prisés comme un
surhomme qui ne dort jamais est de
l'argent en permanence à des femmes
magnifiques genre 19 enfants je veux
dire il fait tout il fait vraiment
beaucoup de choses mais c'est évidemment
du marketing il est une mère modèle
aussi imaginer ça il fait aussi ça c'est
incroyable et les géniales il fait est
qu'on ne peut pas tous être comme alone
en fait si vous le rencontriez je suis
sûr que vous verriez qu'une partie est
vrai est une autre pas du tout et le
fait est que
bonjour nous sommes tous des mini
influenceurs même les ados avec leur
compte instagram et tik tok créer un
monde artificiel pour ceux qui les
entourent en réalité et ce qu'il
présente sur internet n'est pas
franchement en adéquation et oui nous
avons créé ce monde où le succès l objet
de marketing et tout le monde ressent le
besoin d'être en concurrence
à patrick ça a été un plaisir de parler
avec vous du faux beau et du faux mots
j'espère que vous un ventre et un
nouveau terme bientôt afin d'enregistrer
une nouvelle émission merci beaucoup
bonne chance
merci beaucoup prenez soin de vous
[Musique]